but tvp is not called blunt propaganda
or not the name I don't know the name of someone
It's called public television.
here we have 1: 1 corvin party
Corvinus party is called the defense protection coalition
Renewal of the Republic
Freedom and hope dry
Korwin is nowhere like this
no no collision renewal republic
Freedom and Hope
and it's all by accident
so it turned out in the corvette
The world is full of coincidence
Incredible
You see how things are happening
you wouldn't think
I would not think
that this is a coincidence
that it has something to do with Janusz korwin-mccre
But okay.
you plowed me then
no ploughed
be trusted and met in the free market